[Music]
oh my gosh i love your dress thank you
oh my god it's like a little cake but
blower i like it it's very cool nice to
meet you i'm very excited so i'm going
to breathe through this excitement i am
such a fan of oh so this is everything
right now that's so nice
thank you
so okay my fan girl i'm gonna try oh my
gosh you made me feel good thank you i
feel awesome now um well tell us the
story i heard that there's a cool story
of how you got your name what is what is
that yes uh the internet likes to say i
was born in a shell station i wasn't but
it is tight in there the internet's dumb
my mom was getting her car worked on at
a shell station and she went into labor
and the guy who was helping like keep
her calm called the ambulance his name
was chris yeah and so she wanted to name
me after him and so she thought well
chris shell crechelle
oh that's kind of sweet i wasn't born in
a shell station but yeah my dad liked to
say good thing it wasn't a texaco you'd
be sexico
it's sort of an office
so wait your new memoir i love the title
it's called under construction so why
did you go with that well i feel like
you know uh life is a lot of work
getting it right and i feel like you
never really get to that place where
you're like okay i figured it out it's
always going to be ups and downs and so
i being in real estate i feel like it's
like you know it's a constant
construction proc project yeah and so
that's how it feels where it's like you
know it does take work but it's worth
the work yeah it is i feel like we're
always under construction i feel like if
you aren't
always under construction and you've
stopped growing you've stopped
progressing you know and i feel like we
want to do that right yeah because i
think in my head before i thought oh
those people haven't figured out if i
can just get i can't yeah when i started
realizing yeah when i'm 40 yeah that's
never happened yeah
that's a depressing notion but it's true
it never happens you just keep you just
keep growing it there it is um so you
talk openly about your exes i often
write about my situations like that like
in music and it's very therapeutic for
me was it therapeutic for you
your music has gotten me through many a
breakup so thank you for that
me too
so thank you you've helped all of us
um and yeah i do think that this was you
know just a cathartic situation because
so much is said out there and sometimes
there's not a lot of context or clarity
yeah yeah and coming from a place of you
know
of a healing place like i i i am past
those things i am healed there's no
anger there so it's nice to kind of you
know give context and you know tell a
story that i know a lot of people have
related to that you know these things
happen and whether it you know sometimes
they're not all great and you know
instagram and stuff you only see the
good stuff the filters
you know get into the real stuff and
explain how you go from there to yeah
getting back to the good part
[Music]